[Música]
eu vou falar sobre as plantas e
fotossíntese
eu vou falar sobre nós humanos depois eu
vou falar sobre esse palavrão aqui só
títulos estáveis
ainda bem que ninguém pode sair da no
meio da palestra é e vou começar a
entrar no na palestra propriamente dita
que é você você é o que você come e
padrões alimentares dos brasileiros para
encerrar a 1 e difícil de acreditar mas
não tinha oxigênio milhões de anos nove
oxigênio na atmosfera
quem começou a jogar oxigênio na
atmosfera foram essas bactérias chamadas
cianobactérias
essas bactérias que desenvolveram um
aparato para fazer o que nós chamamos de
fotossíntese e um sub a fotossíntese a
transformação do co2 atmosférico em uma
molécula orgânica de carbono para fazer
é essa transformação a a planta ou a
cianobactéria pega o co2 do ar que entra
num ciclo bioquímico e o produto final
essa matéria orgânica mas o subproduto
desse processo fotossintético é o
oxigênio então graças a essas a pequenas
bactérias que nós existimos hoje elas
que deram há condições para a atmosfera
se o que elas eu hoje permitir a nossa
vida a existem dois tipos de
fotossíntese na natureza um chá existem
três mas vou falar só desses dois
principais e chama-se 3 por que ao
transformar o co2 que tem um carbono na
primeira molécula de cor orgânica e
carbono formada essa molécula tem três
carbono saiu nomes e 3 a 1
depois de algum tempo surgiram as
plantas do tipo c4 essas plantas fazem
um tipo de fotossíntese diferente e o
co2 é transformado em uma molécula não
de três de quatro carlos por isso que é
chamando fotossíntese c4
e quais seriam as plantas c3 e c4 a a
maioria das plantas são 63 mais 260 mil
os pés
todas as árvores são se três todas as
frutíferas são c3 com exceção do abacaxi
que tem outro tipo um terceiro tipo de
fotossíntese que eu não vou falar a
todos os legumes todos os cereais arroz
trigo com exceção do milho que é c 4 e
todas as leguminosas feijão e soja
então a grande maioria das plantas que
nós comemos são c3 alimentação básica do
brasileiro arroz feijão e farinha de
mandioca arroz c3 feijão c3 farinha se
três as plantas e 4 pesadas têm um
número menor elas comercialmente são
muito expressivas cana de açúcar que faz
uma super que faz a cachaça que faz um e
por aí adiante
todas as gramíneas tropicais todas as
pastagens braquiária grama de campo de
futebol de grama de jardim
todas essas gramíneas são gramíneas
tropicais forrageiras que é o que nosso
rebanho como é que o nosso gado se
alimenta e milho que é um cereal ea o
único cereal do tipo c4
então a nossa alimentação é composta de
plantas e 3 e plantas e 4 se você for um
brasileiro legítimo você vai comer só se
três arroz feijão e farinha
mas o brasil também toma cachaça então
aí já entra c4 querendo ou não
o brasileiro come pipoca entre um
pouquinho desse quadro
opa muito bem eu estabeleci o que a
fotossíntese mostrei as plantas e 3 e 4
agora vou falar um pouquinho de nós os
humanos e nossos padrões de alimentação
nós começamos com caçadores coletores
que são os caçadores coletores
a gente saía pra pela natureza coletando
alimentos
então na hora do almoço é todo mundo
dessa sala saía pelo campus aqui pelo
bonito os campos da da unisul coletando
alimentos nós eram os caçadores e
coletores
era uma vida simples depois a cerca de
10 a 11 mil anos atrás agricultura
surgiu provavelmente como uma hora de
evento tecnológico da história da
humanidade
vocês acham que uma ordem evento
tecnológico da vida de vocês é o iphone
não é é a agricultura porque a
agricultura é um evento tão importante
para a nossa formação
outros começaram a levar a água para os
agricultores
outros começaram a vigiar a a armazém
onde estava guardado os alimentos outros
vieram assistir palestra ted e assim a
utilização foi se estruturando então
agricultor nós somos o que somos por
causa da agricultura não por causa do
google do iphone do steve jobbs não nós
somos o que nós somos porque existe
alguma coisa agricultura que permitiu
divisão de trabalho e as civilizações se
formaram ter essa divisão de trabalho ea
nossa sociedade hoje é toda estruturada
dessa maneira nós podemos dividir o
trabalho porque tem alguém produzindo
alimento pra gente
ah então como eu falei surgiram as
civilizações baseada na agricultura mas
no começo os romanos por exemplo como
entrego os egípcios comiam o que era
produzido no vale do nilo talvez um
faraó mandasse buscar o morango na
macedônia mas o povão e eu que estava
sendo produzido no local não existia uma
troca de alimentos entre continentes
não existe uma troca de produtos essas
trocas começaram em 1492 com colombo que
descobriu a américa que ele achava que
era a índia ele achava que ele estava
dando a volta ao mundo e aí começou
começaram as trocas por exemplo tomar
conta do molho é molho e tá então não
acho que o olho é é existiu desde sempre
na itália não antes do colombo não tinha
tomate na europa
o tomate foi domesticado aqui no nosso
continente a milho foi domesticado no
méxico cacau foi domesticado no brasil
todo tinha chocolate normal
pelo contrário não existe um cavalo
saque do nosso continente não existiam
bovinos não existia trigo
então após colombo e as grandes
descobertas pedro álvares cabral e tetra
o mundo começou a trocar alimentos entre
continentes pessoas entre continentes e
alimentação começou a ficar de uma certa
forma um pouco mais globalizada
obviamente não tinha produto chinês
disponível como tem hoje nosso
supermercado mas já começou batata a
europa por exemplo
todo mundo acha que é batata alguma
coisa alemã porque todo alemão com
batata não a batata foi domesticada
também aqui na américa central depois
das trocas de colombo veio a revolução
industrial com a revolução industrial
veio a máquina a vapor
vieram os navios essa troca começou a
ficar cada vez maior mais acelerada até
que nós chegamos nos dias de hoje não
tenha chamado a aérea dos supermercados
hoje você entra num supermercado tem
mais de 5 mil produtos
se você tiver a curiosidade e talvez
tenha produto de mais de dez países no
supermercado
esses supermercados têm sorocaba tem
piracicaba onde eu moro tem qualquer
cidade mediana do mundo então é hoje
esse tipo de alimentação que temos nós
vivemos a era do supermercado mas será
que todo todo shakira será que a nossa
alimentação já tá tão organizada que a
gente não consegue perceber diferenças
regionais aqui no brasil é isso que nós
vamos tentar responder é daqui a pouco e
agora é a parte se eu consegui mudar a
parte penosa da palestra que os outros
estáveis né
é um palavrão mas exóticos são aquele os
átomos que tem o mesmo número de de
prótons do núcleo atômico mas tem
números de número de nêutrons diferente
então um isótopo carbono 13 o carbono
carbono 12 carbono 13
os dois são carbono só que esse aqui tem
um neutro a mais então é um pouco mais
pesado mesma coisa o nitrogênio
12 é o isótopo mais abundante e
nitrogênio 15 é o mais raro e tenho o
neutro mas é um pouco mais pesado
ainda bem que ninguém pode levantar é
então natureza eu tenho muito carbono
deu 12 muito nitrogênio 14 pouco carbono
13 pouco nitrogênio 15
como aqui pouco como a que pouco é muito
aqui é pouco é muito trabalhar com esse
número é horrível 10.000 ninguém
consegue então se criou essa notação
delta c13 delta n 15 é só a relação de
uma mostra em relação a um padrão é só
isso
mas não se preocupe só se preocupa com
delta c13 e delta n 15
agora graças a deus por isso que eu
tenho emprego e se deltas e 13 das
plantas e 3 é diferente das plantas e 4
gastas a deus então milho é diferente de
batata cana é diferente de de trigo
qual é o terceiro que eu não falei cana
milho enfim a c4 são diferentes da cdu
foi as gramíneas as gramíneas a quando
você come picanha você está comendo
capim de uma forma disfarçada de um
gosto mais apetitoso exato porque o
produtor inicial a fotossíntese a
gramínea brasileiro é um carrinho
ambulante e esse delta n 15 aqui ele tem
uma característica muito interessante
ele vai aumentando conforme você vai
subindo na cadeia trófica cadeia trófica
assim aquela cadeira sabe a galinha como
o milho o o o gavião come e não quem
come galinha
nós como hóquei a boa após a como a
galinha e o cachorro do mato como raposo
isso é uma cadeia trófica nós temos uma
cadeia trófica aaa a fotossíntese
plantas aí por exemplo os vegetarianos e
veganos eles param aqui não não é
demérito é verdade eles estão não servem
se tornou num degrau menor da caneta
aí nós que somos unidos que comemos
carne e vegetais nós estamos acima dos
enganos na cadeia trófica então conforme
você vai subindo na cadeia trófica esse
delta n 15 vai aumentando porque quando
a gente faz chichico com a gente deixa
mais átomo de n 14 para trás e fica mais
atuante e 15 no nosso corpo
então quanto mais carnívoro você for
mais um seu delta n 15 vai ser maior
então provavelmente o delta enix dos
gaúchos deve ser muito maior que o nosso
delta n 15 porque teoricamente escolhe
muito mais carne que a gente então o
delta n 15 de um de um homem livro é
diferente do que de um de um vegetariano
totalmente diferente e essa é uma
maneira de pegar porque hoje vegetariano
tá na moda chegando mas ainda então foi
um pedacinho da sua unha aí 15 minutos
eu digo setass é vegetariano não e
vários já pegamos várias mentiras não
ser vegetariano
ah eu sou mais eu comecei a semana
passada não é sr vegetariano realmente
eu sou mas de vez em quando como frango
aí mas minha tia faz um churrasco então
não é vegetariano
então a gente pega fácil esse tipo de
coisa com delta n 15 muito bem então só
pra dar uma liturgia na palestra se eu
mostrar um gráfico de seu comércio 36
por cento de x e y
diferente das duas brilhantes palestra
que antecedeu a sua carteira de ano
então só pra mostrar que o tal do delta
se três das plantas e 3 - 28 esquece -
aqui só por mil e cem por cento é por
mil ea que menos 12 kells e 4 das
plantas - 12 - 28 num equipamento que a
gente tem que chama espectrômetro de
massas é uma diferença acaba lá a gente
mede facilmente e a 1 o delta n 15 como
eu falei vai sumindo até ao longo da
cadeia trófica isso já mostrei vou
passar rápido então como processos
digestivos e de assimilação dos
nutrientes carbono nitrogênio pouco
alteram a composição isotópica essa
reforma essa ferramenta torna se um
potente indicador de padrões alimentares
e humanos e outras espécies animais
então
isotópica mente você é o que você come
né quando é o cabelo de e faz 30 anos
quando aula faz 30 anos que eu falo por
pessoas não lêem a transparência o que
causa medo de fazer eu li transparece
notar no total do ted que vai aparecer
no mundo inteiro eo google
sei lá eu vou falar nada mas é bom então
o que a gente fez nosso laboratório nós
saímos medido tudo que é tipo de
alimento no brasil nós analisamos mais e
sei lá mil alimentos
então é a bebida aqui tem vinho cerveja
é vinho mas viúva é é c3 c3 mais cerveja
e cevada e lúpulo c3 é certeza mas o
professor como é que tens e 4 aqui
porque ele expõe açúcar no rio
brasileiro faz cerveja de milho a então
a ce 4ta e lugares que você não imagina
shoyu show ea molho de soja todos maria
do show no brasil foi de milho então
devia se chama show deixava-me shoyu uma
coisa assim
o cereal c3 milho há peixe nós temos
peixe na áera é selvagem peixe não em
cativeiro em peixes em cativeiro que o
do milho e o peixe fica parecido com uma
pamonha que olha esse quadro
aqui a cadeia alimentar um boizinho uma
galinha sem um pouquinho toda a nossa
cadeia alimentar é baseada ou em capim e
milho então como eu falei se você come
muito milho você tem um esse delta c3
aqui parecido com isso aqui ó
há alimento processado alimento
processado incluiu tudo sorvete
chocolate biscoito que mais que é
processado yogurte processado queijo
barrinha de cereal que está na moda tudo
isso elemento processado
esses alimentos processados eles têm de
tudo eles têm alguns que são puro c4 e
alguns que são puros e treinar os olhos
tem de tudo aqui
aí depois eu tenho um feijão ea soja eo
todos os vegetais aqui são se 3
eu faço a mesma coisa para o delta n 15
e o que eu faço é o próprio delta c13
conta delta e 15
nós fizemos uma relação entre o delta
c13 médio do município e o idh índice de
desenvolvimento humano que é composto é
da onu e é com o índice é composto por
renda saúde e educação
então quanto mais aos mais alto esse
índice de desenvolvimento humano mais
rico é o município que sorocaba tem os
maiores e de a gás do brasil
então nós conseguimos eu não sei por que
essa relação incrível entre o delta
certeza os municípios eo idh e essa é a
equação que que traduz essa reta então
se eu jogar o idh aqui tá aqui ó eu sei
o delta c13 médio de cada município
brasileiro
eu tenho 5.500 municípios não poderia
coletar 1 em 5.500 municípios que não
têm dinheiro fazer isso mas eu tenho de
hds 5.500 municípios
eu joguei e fiz esse mapa esse mapa é o
delta c13 médio de cada município
brasileiro
quanto mais azul mais e 4 quanto menos
azul mais c3
então são paulo desenvolvido e dh
superalto nós somos uma uma área azul
lançou o mar desse quadro
nós somos isotópica mente totalmente
homogêneos não tem diferença nenhuma
quando você vai para as regiões mais
pobres do brasil norte nordeste você
começa a haver maior quantidade c3 que
arroz feijão e farinha
então pra terminar no futuro que a gente
espera que com a penetração do mercado e
se deus quiser o produto o poder
aquisitivo do brasileiro aumentando e se
parte do mapa provavelmente vai se
tornar a azul vai aumentar o consumo de
4 e essa parte do mapa provavelmente vai
começar a amar e lá vai começar a manela
porque cada vez mais nós estamos
passando a ser um carnívoro pra comer
mais plantas nós estamos tendo essa
consciência nós estamos diminuindo a
quantidade de ingestão animam então isso
que a gente prevê para o futuro eu já tô
atrasado obrigado pela atenção pelo
convite